I had my son on the other side of the
table here and what he does he looks up
questions in quote Cora and typically
physics question but in general but
science in general and I'm gonna do my
best to answer them off the top of my
head what we can't answer online in real
time well they we take this homework and
I try to answer it for you tomorrow
or as soon as I possibly can do a little
research on it if I need to or whatever
it takes and so without further ado my
son is now gonna ask me the first
question and you're welcome all
obviously after I answer the question to
put your comments questions anything you
have in the comment section of YouTube
there okay let's start the day what is
the biggest problem in physics that
scientists are trying to solve today
that's a nice one that's why what's the
biggest problem or what is one of the
biggest problems in physics the
scientists are trying to solve today you
know there's a separate list of these
and they make them I guess every year
there's a list of unsolved problems in
physics which was the first one what we
don't tell about let's see if we can no
no isn't it a list there because they
usually have the list of the most
important second third something like
that you know they usually have this
okay let's see what do they have what is
matter made of okay number two
is why is gravity so weird not necessary
usually it's science it's the science
division of MBC tomorrow 3:00 is the
first one on the Wikipedia question yes
why this time seem to flow only in one
direction arrow of time why this time
heavy direction well again the first
three they have nothing to do with
science so we reject all three of them
again it shows that we have a problem a
more fundamental problem and that's
understanding what science is what
physics is about we're trying to answer
how does the invisible world work we
already know how the visible world works
you know you have to explain why the
window broke well you have your theory
you see well it was a rock that Joey
threw through the window and the glass
fell on the floor and you know just
broke him into him the glass fell right
another guy says no your neighbor he
hates you and he came in with a crowbar
and just smashed your window another guy
says no your dog jumped through the
window so you got all these theories but
we understand them all because we can
illustrate every participant every actor
that we are using to explain our theory
imagine them right you can imagine them
and you can make a little movie of them
I can make a movie of the rock I can
make a movie of the rock you know I
didn't make a picture of the rock I can
make a movie of the rock flying through
the window breaking the window glass
falling on the floor I know you do it
with a program your neighbor with the
dog all those that are visible we can do
that no problem whatsoever
piece of cake and we've left that in the
past and we call it classical mechanics
because we can all understand that it's
like you know kids says stuff today it's
very straightforward and it's
straightforward because it can be
Illustrated because you can you know not
only imagine
as you can visualize you know even
closing your eyes you can visualize each
one of the actors doing their thing but
you know if you can't visualize it like
you know we have the et or the Martian
come here to earth we can make a movie
and show them the movie and say look
this what I'm talking about
but what about the invisible entities
what about light the mediator of light
what about gravity the mediator Rabi
what about magnetism atomic and
subatomic behavior you know how does all
that being done that's where we run into
trouble we run into trouble because what
mathematical physics has done it's
replaced objects with concepts and so it
focuses on the concepts and forgets all
about the object